prison that's what i'm saying i can't i
don't regret going to prison at
all what was that like what was it like
the day they told you how much time did
you get 12 years yeah
you did every you did all 12. so my no
no i didn't so
i did uh just just shy of i did around
six years
six so now so
three four months after sentencing i'm
in prison
um my lawyer calls me sets up a call and
he says hey listen so the dea toxicology
report came back
you're the substance that how they
sentenced you and how it's
and how it really measures up is they're
saying it's 50 percent
they just again how do they come up with
these numbers man
so like do they have some guinea pig
that they're that they're testing the
drugs with i don't understand how they
come up with it but they said 50 percent
as potent as the
as they initially thought so that
justified a three-level departure which
took
almost three years off the sentence so
almost four is like three and a half
years so that's big
a big reduction and then when i was
incarcerated they have what's called the
ardap program
and that stands for the residential drug
and alcohol abuse treatment program
that's a nine month program if you
complete it in nine months it's
residential so you move to a drug dorm
you're with other people who have
recognized that they have a
substance abuse problem i was
diagnosed with chronic marijuana abuse
disorder
[Laughter]
so at the advice of my lawyer i made
sure that they knew
that i had a marijuana abuse problem
before i went to prison
wow and it works it does work and you
know what's funny people pay these
prisons
these white collar guys that are like
terrified to death they're going to
prison they got caught
stealing a couple million dollars they
go to prison they're like well no i'm
going to do 10 years
this is not good and their lawyer's like
don't worry man you're going to get a
year off for this you're going to get a
year off for that
don't worry man you're only going to do
five and they're not wrong
i mean if you stay on good behavior
which is not hard to do in federal
prison
it's not hard to not get in trouble in
federal prison i mean it's it's really
not
so i mean you might get caught taking a
banana out of the chow hall they're
going to make you push a pink lawnmower
for an hour
you know it's they're not going to throw
you in the hole for that
um you know that
you you mind your own business stay in
your own lane work out read
do things that are productive um a lot
of great people in there there's a lot
of scumbags too
but a lot of great people it's not hard
to mind your own business man
be respectful be polite don't put your
feet in other people's chairs i saw a
guy almost get
killed for using someone's chair as a
footstool
that's not smart think about it you wear
those shoes in the bathroom everywhere
you go
but people that are coming these white
collar guys coming straight off the
street they're not thinking like that
you were in this
low security though right and fci fci
coleman
and then i went to pensacola camp so
when i got to pensacola that's on a navy
base
that i think what's her name bar um
i'm trying to think of her name she
wrote an article about pensacola like
in the late 90s how it was like club fed
um
you have to google it pensacola club fed
sansa cola club fed
that's your cue aiden so you know she
wrote this article
blew it up said these are the conditions
we had a movie theater like a real movie
theater
um gourmet food back
then prison was not a bad experience
they even had co-ed federal prisons
where men and women were together you
didn't wear
jumpsuits or greens or khakis you wore
street clothes
you know it's uh and even at pensacola
they didn't have the
movie theater was no longer active due
to asbestos or whatever
but excuse me we did have movie night
and pretty much every night after 4 p.m
they play movies in the visiting room
on a big screen and you know you can pop
popcorn bring food do whatever
really man
it and i hate saying this like i'm not
trying to
it's not a bad thing it's a good thing
that without it you know there's no
conjugal visits so you take the
conjurors you got to give these guys
something
yeah so but you know the camaraderie and
i made more friends at pensacola than i
probably made in my entire life
really and oh man my buddy mark fraser
um
he's over in indian harbor beach he
owned uh like pill mills
he now he refuses to call that but he
owned multiple locations there were pain
clinics
people they were bringing people in by
the bus load they were prescribing them
you know just to they were selling
oxycontin
and the dea came in and said you can't
do that no more you're going to prison
and you know i met multiple people that
were in that line of work i think he got
five years
um i worked out with him every day he
was my workout partner
i'm hoping to see him while i'm here in
florida great dude
i mean one of the one of the best dudes
i've ever met
and so like i really made him a great
dude if he was selling oxycontin to
loads of people well i know
right so but but look at what i was
doing yeah and
and we i'm i'm curious what makes him so
great
i mean he has integrity if he tells you
he's gonna do something for you he does
it he'll give you the shirt off of his
back
um he's not gonna steal from you he's
not gonna lie to you
uh i mean what really constitutes what
really makes someone a good person you
know what i mean is it
a mistake that they made the wrong path
that they took in life the wrong turn
you know
we're all capable of making mistakes and
i think most people have probably done
something in their life that they could
have went to jail for
i think there's a book called like three
felonies a day it talks about it how
even a federal judge is committing three
felonies a day and doesn't even know it
so i mean there's thousands there's what
200 000 laws in this country
it's just ridiculous yeah i mean if you
distill all those laws down
don't hurt people and don't take their
[ __ ] it's as simple as that
right why do you have to pervert justice
why do you have to confuse
things you know why do you have to
create all these thousands of laws
it's always don't hurt industry don't
hurt people yeah
and you know and and that and that's
where in in the rdap program which i'm
so
that's where i met mark in the rdap
program i'm so grateful that i had an
opportunity now of course i took this
program to get a year off my sentence
that's why i took it that's why
everybody takes it right but in the
program
what what it really does it's based on
cbt cognitive behavioral therapy
and it helps us connect the dots between
activating events between something
happening
and the way we feel the idea is that
there's something that happens in the
middle of those two things
and in the middle of those two things is
our cognitions
it's our thinking and we think in
patterns so when we develop a thinking
pattern
these patterns persist that's what
patterns do so
they pull something in front of you a
little bit more you can use my back if
you're if you want to be over there you
can pull it
so so these patterns persist and
and they wreak havoc in our lives and
the thing is it's so easy to point a
finger and be like
well you made me feel this way or you
did this and you did that and it made me
feel this way
but the thing is is all we're doing is
pushing the blame when
in reality it's not what someone else
did
that made me feel the way i feel it's
what i thought
about what they did that made me feel
the way i feel the meaning you put to it
right but but the idea is you know we
have 70 000 cognitions a day
and most of those are irrational like 80
of those are totally irrational
really yeah most of our thinking is
irrational like right
so now we think about it hopefully
before we
get down to the feelings the actions and
the outcome before we act or respond
we think about it and we do the right
thing so
by evaluating the way i'm thinking by
realizing that
the way i feel like when i real the
number we call it a
a rational self-analysis an rsa
so you know i write down what happened i
write down what i thought about what
happened that might be 10 different
things
and then i write down how i felt how did
i feel
it all starts for me the way i do it and
i still do them today
the way i do it is when i feel some way
that i don't want to feel when i realize
i'm sad
or i'm angry or i'm disappointed
i'm frustrated i'm stressed out
something's not adding up
then i just have i sometimes i should do
it more than i do but
but you know i write down the feeling
first and
then i draw like a little emoji or
emoticon that kind of symbolizes how i
feel
and then i try to evaluate what led to
me feeling that way
because through that it's just exercise
man if you want your muscles to get
bigger you lift weights
if you want your brain to get sharper if
you want to think better you evaluate
your thinking you exercise your thinking
and
over time the idea is that your thinking
patterns get a little better
so interesting so you're kind of like
back engineering the way you feel
into like thoughts right and things
funny the
program if you take it seriously it
turns into it turns you into like a
psychologist
for real i i love it i think is it rdat
rdap residential drug and alcohol abuse
treatment program
okay something like that
so